في تركيا وفي اليوم التاسع على وقوع
الزلزال وبعد مضي 1998 ساعه نجحت فرق
الانقاذ في كهرمان مراش في اخراج شقيقين
على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض
الله
ان شاء الله
تركي
الانقاذ من اخراج شاب يبلغ من العمر 18
عاما من تحت الانقاض
ماما
وفي ولايتها تاي التركيه انتشرت فرق
الانقاذ شخصا من تحت الانقاض بعد مرور 183
ساعه للوقوع زلزال كهربا مرعش الذي ضرب
جنوبيا البلاد
يتابع مع مراسلينا ايضا من داخل اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد في انقره
مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان شوقي ومن ولايه
اديمان مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ومن غازي
عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر ابو نبود ومن
جديد اليك فرح الزمان
لمتابعه المعلومات الوارده من مركز افاد
حسن في الحقيقه لم تعد افات تنشر
المعلومات بذات الفروقات الزمنيه التي كان
عليها او جرى عليها الحال خلال الايام
الماضيه نحن نتحدث عن اعلان واحد يوم امس
لحصيله القتلى والجرحى لا فوارق في عدد
الجرحى لكن فارق كبير في عدد القتلى ونحن
ما زلنا ننتظر حصيله جديده تعلن عنها افات
في الساعات القادمه ولربما يوكل ذلك
للرئيس التركي او لاحد الوزراء اذ انهم
سيعقدون اجتماعا حكوميا هنا في مقر افاد
بعد المشاركه في
اداره هذه العمليات والاشراف عليها في
غرفه تنسيق العمليات في اداره الطوارئ
والكوارث في انقره لكن طالما ان الحديث
يجري بحسب الرئاسه التركيه عن استمرار
الاعمال حتى اخراج اخر شخص عالق تحت
الانقاض فنحن امام طويله وعصيبه وامام
حصيله من المتوقع بل انه من المؤكد انها
ستكون اعلى من الارقام الموجوده لدينا حتى
الان
الاعمال تجري الان بالتركيز على بعض
المناطق لا سيما ان هنالك احياء قد
انتهت فيها عمليات
الانقاذ وتم توجيه هذه الطواقم الى مناطق
ثانيه على ما يبدو وبحسب بيانات افاد فان
التركيز الان يجري على مدينه انطاكيا فيها
تاي اذ انه اعلم بانها المنطقه الاكثر
تضررا في الزلزال اصلاح مطار هاتاي
واعادته الى الخدمه من شانه ان يسهل ويسرع
في ايصال طواقم الانقاذ والمزيد من
المساعدات المساعدات التي تاتي من الداخل
والخارج بحسب
تصريحات المسؤولين وعلى راسهم وزير
الخارجيه التركي على ما يبدو فانها وان
وصلت الى كثيرين لكنها لن تكون ك لاسيما
اننا نتحدث عن حجم كارثه كبيره عن حجم
دبار كبير عن عدد كبير من
المنكوبين وسيكون هنالك ضروره لتوفير
المساعدات على مدى طويل لا نتحدث عن الان
او على المستقبل القريب وانما مدى طويل لا
سيما مع تحديد سقف سنه واحده لاعاده اعمار
هذه المباني لكن نحن في انتظار الارقام
الان يدور سؤال هام للغايه حسن هل سيستطيع
هذا الزلزال او هذين هذين الزلزالان في
الحقيقه ان ياخذاه لقب اكبر زلزال في
تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه ما زلنا حتى الان
عند حصيله ارقام تضعه في المرتبه الثانيه
بعد زلزال الزنجان الذي وقع في عام
1939 لكن باجراء مقارنه بسيطه ذاك الزلزال
كانت شدته اعلى هذا الزلزال شدته اخف
نتحدث عن حجم اضرار كبير الغايه عن زلزال
اليوم الذي وقع على عمق سبعه كيلو متر وهو
يعتبر قريب من سطح الارض ادى لدمار كبير
اذا نحن في الساعات القادمه سنكون امام
مقارنه حصيلتين زلزال ارزنجان الذي ادى
الى مقتل ما يقارب 33 الف شخص وزلزال
كهرمان مرش الذي ادى الى الان الى مقتل ما
يقارب 32 الف